one of the biggest points in the Muslim
calendar starting next week Ramadan
coronavirus of course is so disruptive
for everyone at the minute but what does
it mean specifically for Muslims in the
weeks ahead
good morning Sophie yeah absolutely I
think we as a nation have been faced
with this huge lockdown to keep everyone
safe and this will prove very
challenging time for Muslims who
generally enter Ramadan as so to speak
in fasting and also trying to work with
other than and basically it's all about
giving and sharing so while it's the
spiritual month for us to come together
and practice our faith it's a time when
we would spend a lot of time doing a lot
of charitable work going out and meeting
people go into the mosques so it's it's
going to be very different to our
previous experience in the UK yeah I can
certainly see that as you say a time
when you often reach out to other people
who share your faith you have to
socially distance what kind of changes
will people have to make so what we're
pushing from the Muslim Council of
Britain and many Muslims up and down the
country as mosques are all closed and
it's it's a hive of activity during the
month of Ramadan we've we're putting out
a campaign this week called Ramadan at
home so it'd be very different it's
really about families staying indoors
fasting together and also breaking
they're fast together as families within
their own homes and then looking at
innovative ways in how they can share
this experience through online methods
as we're doing for many different things
nowadays using social media and so on
but also encouraging people to still be
charitable and support campaigns again
through online methods and yet we still
have many mosques and people up and down
the country who continue to volunteer
helping those who are most vulnerable in
media it's very difficult time
interesting for you to talk about the
importance of charitable giving we know
of course how concerned our charities
are at the minute that donations are
drying up because of the hardship
through a cope at 19 how important do
you think
the month of ramadhan could be in trying
to tackle that it's it's it's vital for
us so there was a campaign launched a
couple weeks ago where many of the
Muslim charities came together pooling
or national solidarity campaign bringing
together all of the major charities
within the UK to raise funds to support
all of those needs similarly just this
weekend we've launched another campaign
as we know all of the mosques in the UK
are closed many of them are terrible
organizations and they are really
struggling for funds to sustain
themselves and to keep their staff so
we've launched a campaign again in
partnership with organization called
launch good and also the Muslim
charities forum bringing together trying
to pull everyone's support where every
mosque can use this platform to raise
funds for their institutions at the same
time many of the international NGOs they
are also raising money historically each
year Muslim charities in especially in
the month of Ramadan raise over 100
million pounds just from the UK alone
now I just wonder British Muslims often
from pame backgrounds I just wonder are
you alarmed to have seen the statistics
that show that those from non white
backgrounds appear to be more vulnerable
to cope it 19 we of course don't know
the reasons for it but is that something
that is causing concern well from the
reports I've seen over the last few last
couple of weeks with some of the deaths
that have been announced quite publicly
from doctors and medics as well as
friends and family that I've seen
through various social media output it's
quite apparent it seems that there is it
seems to be quite a high number of
people from beer-beer me backgrounds
black and minority ethnic backgrounds
and we'll start Muslim as well which is
which is a real concern for us so we are
seeing a voice growing I've seen many
articles around raising this concern but
it is really something of concern for us
so initially we heard that it will
affect people who are over 70 or with
underlying health conditions and if we
look at BMI communities actually
underlying health conditions healthy
inequalities living in some of the most
deprived areas in the UK they would be
the most vulnerable